Okay.
Bayer, the massive pharmaceutical manufacturer
has bailed out on two major Fox News.
Opinion shows, uh, that's me pretending that
there's actually a significant difference
between Fox opinion and Fox News reporting
moments and programs and hosts.
A Bayer has pulled advertising from Tucker
Carlson's show and from Laura Ingram's show.
Now both of these shows you might know have
already had serious advertising issues because
of the shows are toxic and Bayer has been
a major advertiser.
Bayer was Tucker's fifth largest advertiser
and Laura Ingram, second largest advertiser.
And the reason for the cancellation is being
reported as white nationalist rhetoric on
Tucker Carlson's show, uh, and Laura Ingram
defending a white supremacist named Paul Nealon
on her program.
And interestingly, Bayer has actually a little
while ago, started reducing and pulling ads
off of these shows.
Now it's being formally reported based on
contacts with Bayer.
So what I want to do here is cut through all
of the bs for you because even within our
audience, the idea of an advertiser boycott
is controversial.
Sometimes when we talk about advertiser boycotts,
people will make so called free speech arguments
against the ad boycotts.
Even though you can't argue against the reality
that calling for a boycott is a form of speech.
A company deciding where to advertise using
whatever system they want to use to figure
out where to advertise is a form of speech.
So there's this weird thing about criticizing
add boycotts and demands for ad boycotts on
the basis of free speech because it is a form
of speech in and of itself to say to a company,
please don't advertise on this show.
There are some times sort of weird business
regulation arguments that people will make
against ad boycotts, although I don't even
understand those in this context, so I don't
even know how to refute them.
They just don't make any sense to me.
Here's the bottom line.
As I tweeted yesterday.
If you don't like the fact that advertiser
boycotts can negatively impact shows that
you watch shows that you listen to, shows
that you like.
If you don't want advertiser cancellations
to be a threat to programs that you think
are good programs, stop making media reliant
on ad dollars.
What I mean by this is if we didn't have a
system where shows depended on advertising
money, then the ad boycott would lose its
place as a threat to the existence of programming.
This is why I've been trying to grow our direct
membership for years.
I know that we joke about how much I talk
about membership or whatever.
Every dollar that we get from membership is
a dollar of what I would call immunity from
advertisers, from Youtube, demonetization,
which we'll talk about later because that's
happening.
Again, Facebook, demonetization, this couldn't
be more obvious one way or another.
You are paying for the show.
Okay?
You either watch an ad and pay with your attention
and then the advertiser is the one that actually
makes the financial transfer of dollars directly
or you pay the producer directly through a
membership through a pledge drive on NPR or
PBS through a cable subscription for some
channels.
If we had more direct financial support when
youtube app apocalypse hit in 2017 it wouldn't
have mattered if our level of financial support,
uh, d was decimated from youtube because we
would have that direct support.
In the same way we have advertisers, someone
could, if they wanted to go to our advertisers
and say, I won't support you if you continue
to advertise with David Pakman.
Now I'm guessing most advertisers would say,
David Pakman hasn't said anything discriminatory
or racist or xenophobic.
We don't know why we would pull our ads from
David Pakman, but that would be a threat that
disappears if our level of direct financial
support goes up.
The legal side of this is super clear, like
I'm not making a partisan argument.
Advertising choices are a form of speech period.
Lobbying companies not to advertise or to
advertise on whatever show is a form of speech.
It's protected 100% it's 100% fine.
We can debate whether an ad boycott is a good
strategy.
I think it's great when activism has an impact,
right?
In the real world, it's harder and harder
for an individual's voice to matter.
We know that the, the demands or the desires
of rich people are way more likely to become
law or policy than the demands of poor people
and middle class people, the demands or the
ideas or the, the desires of big corporations
are way more likely to be taken seriously
by our elected officials than those of just
your individual Joe or Sally or whoever.
So in a world where it's harder and harder
for an individual to have their voice heard,
I think it's great when activism has an impact
and it has had an impact through ad boycotts.
But I agree that there is a real problem when
media outlets are so, uh, over a barrel by
advertisers.
And the way to fix that is support the shows
that you like.
If you want them to cover what they want to
cover, not be threatened by the loss of ad
dollars.
If they have a membership program, sign up.
Fox is different.
Number one, they don't actually even really
need to make money because rich right wingers
fund them.
They also don't have membership, but when
it comes to youtube or other platforms, I
mean we know what the solution is under 1%
of our audience are members.
I estimate as I said on the Joe Rogan show,
80 to 85 or even 90% of our audience can afford
two bucks a month.
If we grow our support from under 1% of our
audience to 3% any advertiser that wants to
boycott us can boycott us.
Youtube can be monetized us, it would not
matter and what's most exposed to me by the
controversy of these add boycotts is not really
the debate over the ad boycotts themselves.
My view on that has been clear for a very
long time.
It's that we have a problem that advertisers
have so much power and we know how to fix
it.
Direct supportive shows.
Let me know what you think.
I'm
on Twitter at
the Pacman,